now the standard thing you do with a
recursive data type in programming is
you define recursive procedures on them
so let's look at how that works I'm
going to define a function f on a
recursively defined data type r the way
I'm going to do it is I'm going to
define f of b explicitly in terms of b
and operations that are already
understood for all of the base cases of
B in R and then I'm going to define F of
a constructor applied to X in terms of X
and f of X and if I keep to that
structure that gives me a recursive
definition of the function f on the
recursively defined data set R let's
look at an example to make this recipe
explicit and clearer let's think about a
recursive function on the set of matched
brackets this is a some one interesting
one let's define the depth of a string
as follows and the ideas that's how
deeply nested are they successive pairs
of left and right brackets well the
depth of the empty string is 0 got to
start somewhere
and it's got enough no brackets we'll
call it f 0 now what about the depth of
the constructor putting brackets around
s and then following it by Tay well
putting brackets around s gives you a
string that's one deeper than s is and
then you follow it by Tay and it's as
deep as T is so the result is that the
depth of the constructor is a string
whose which is is a number which is
equal to 1 plus the depth of s and the
depth of T whichever is larger the max
of 1 plus depth of s and depth of T and
that's our recursive definition of depth
let's look at maybe another even more
familiar example of a recursive
definition let's define the nth power of
a an integer or real number
kay the zeroth power of K is defined to
be one and the n plus first power of K
is defined to be K times the nth power
of K and this would be an executable
definition of the exponentiation
function in a lot of programming
languages and my point here is that this
familiar definition a recursive
definition on a non-negative integer n
is in fact a structural induction using
the fact that the natural numbers are
sorry that the non-negative integers can
be defined recursively as follows zero
is a non-negative integer and if N is a
non-negative integer then n plus 1 is a
non-negative integer so to summarize the
recipe for a recursive function
definition is you define f going from
the recursive data type to values
whatever kind of values you want to
assign to these recursive data F of B is
defined directly for the base case B of
base cases B and F of the constructor of
X is defined using f of X and X now once
you've gotten a function defined
recursively you could start proving
things about it by structural induction
or by induction on its own definition or
its own recursive definition so let's
look at an example of that I want to
prove the following property of the
depth of strings in M namely that if I
look at the length of a string R plus 2
so the brackets around R means the the
number of of sorry the vertical bars
around our mean the number of brackets
in the string R plus 2 is less than or
equal to 2 to the power a depth plus 1
twice the 2 to the depths of the string
and I want to prove that this holds for
all strings are of matched brackets and
I'm going to prove it by structural
induction and just as a walk through
here's how the proof is going to go
let's suppose that r is the base case
is it the case that this inequality
holds for the empty string well the
length of our is zero so length of our
plus two is 2 is 0 plus 2 or 2 which is
the same as 2 to the 0 plus 1 which is
in fact equal to 2 to the depth of the
empty string plus 1 so this inequality
actually holds as an equality in the
base case and we're we're good there but
we next leave this show is that this
inequality holds in the constructor case
so we're looking at a an arbitrary
string R that's built out of s and T and
R is left bracket S right bracket P and
I want to show that our satisfies this
inequality well by induction hypothesis
I can assume the S&T satisfy the
inequality so I have that the length of
s plus 2 is at most 2 to the depth of s
plus 1 and the length of T plus 2 is at
most 2 to the depth of T plus 1 and
let's just walk through the proof you
can slow this down and replay it if need
be some you're just going to go through
it quickly the length of our plus 2r is
after all brackets s T so it's simply
the length of that string plus 2 by the
definition of our the length of brackets
s T is the length of T plus the length
of s plus the 2 for the two brackets
that we've added and so we're plugging
that in to the previous term and getting
that plus 2 then just rearrange the
terms it's the same as the size of s
plus 2 plus the size of T plus 2 and I
arranged it that way because by
induction hypothesis I know that the
size of s plus 2 is less than or equal
to 2 to the depth of s plus 1 and
likewise for teh now I just play a nice
trick to get these two exponents to look
alike i I say that the depth of s is
less than or equal to the max of the
depth of s and the depth of T likewise
for the depth of T so in both of those
terms here I can replace the exponent or
replace the depth of s by the max
of depth SNT and likewise here now I've
got the same term twice so I can say
that it's simply twice the max depth and
of course that is equal to by definition
of the depth of our twice to to the
depth of our which is of course two to
the depth of our plus 1 and I have by
more or less automatically plugging into
the definitions and a structural
induction I've proved that this
inequality holds for the recursively
defined depth function and we're done
let's look at one more familiar example
I want to give a recursive definition of
the positive powers of two so the base
case is that 2 is a positive power of 2
and the constructor is just one
constructor I'm going to use that if x
and y are positive powers of 2 then
their product is a positive power of 2
so let's look at some examples I can
start with 2 and then the only thing I
can do as a constructor is multiply 2 by
2 to get 4 once I got 4 I can do 4 times
2 to get 8 and I can do 4 times 4 to get
16 and I can do 4 times 8 to get 32 and
all of these are positive powers of 2
now let's define the log to the base 2
of a positive power of tow recursively
well the log to the base 2 of 2 is 1 I'd
have to define log to the base 2 in the
base case and that's easy to do what
about in the constructor case well the
log to the base 2 of X Y is equal to the
log to the base 2 of X plus the log to
the base 2 of Y for all the X why's that
are positive powers of 2 and so I have
defined log of the constructor X Y in
terms of the function log of X and the
function log applied to Y it conforms to
the standard definition of
a recursive function on a recursively
defined data type the positive powers of
two this looks okay let's just check it
out so log of four is log of 2 times two
which is by the by that definition of
log the log of 2 plus the log of 2 which
is 1 plus 1 which is equal to 2 and
guess what that's correct the log of 8
well 8 is 2 times 4 so by the recursive
definition that's the log of 2 plus the
log of 4 which we previously figured out
log of 4 was 2 so we get 3 and the
answer comes out right now remember
you're not supposed to end this
reasoning use the properties that you
know that log to the base 2 has because
we're defining this function which were
calling log to the base 2 and implicitly
claiming that it's right but in order to
prove that it's right we need to be
using just the the structural definition
of log to the base 2 to prove its
properties so that was what I was
illustrating with this reasoning that
just plugging in the the constructor
case of log of X Y as log of X plus log
of Y I can get these numbers out so the
point of this is just to make the
following definition look reasonable I'm
going to define a new function which I'm
going to call the log e function
it's another function on the positive
powers of 2 and here's the definition of
the log e function the log e of 2 is
going to be one just as the log is but
the log e of XY is gonna be X plus the
log e of Y for all X Y in positive
powers of 2 well let's try that
definition log e of 4 is log you have 2
times 2 which according to the recursive
definition is 2 plus the log e of 2
which is 1 namely it's 3 ok log e of 8
well 8 is 2 times 4 so the log e of 8 is
2 plus the log e of 4 we just figured
out that the loggia 4 was 3 so it's 2
plus 3 is 5
G of 8 is 5 and finally log e of 16 well
16 is 8 times 2 so the log e of 8 times
2 is 8 plus the log e of 2 which we know
is 1 it's 9 so we've just figured out
the log e of 16 is 9 but but now comes
the problem 16 of course is not only 8
times 2 but it's 2 times 8 and so the
log e of 2 times 8 is 2 plus the log e
of 8 log e of 8 we previously figured
out was 5 so the log e of 16 is 7 and
now I have an inconsistency I have used
this recursive definition of log E to
conclude that the log e of 16 is both 9
and 7 and we got a problem it's not a
good definition of a function the
problem is a simple one called ambiguity
there's more than one way to construct
the elements of pp2 of positive powers
of 2 from the constructor x times y 16
was 8 times 2 but it's also 2 times 8
and of course it's also 4 times 4 and
depending on which constructor you use
to construct 16 you're going to get out
different values assigned to the log e
function so when you have an ambiguously
defined recursive data structure for
example F 18 is very ambiguous then
defining a function defining recursive
functions on that definition is not
going to work well and you have to very
carefully prove that if a recursive
definition actually works in his
single-valued so for example log to the
base 2 does work but that would require
proof it doesn't follow on general
principles when you define a recursive
function on a an ambiguous data type
I mean only hand the reason why we chose
that somewhat unexpected single
constructor for the balanced strings am
ballast the balanced bracket strings was
that it turns out
be unambiguous and so that definition of
depth is a good definition as is any
definition based on the recursive
definition of the set M so the general
problem we have to watch out for
instructor created the datum II if
there's more than one way to construct e
then you're gonna you're not quite sure
which case to use to define the function
f and that's why this issue of whether
or not the data structures ambiguous is
critical to getting good definitions of
recursive functions